hugo an open source static site
generator famous for being the fastest
way to render html in the world it was
created in 2015 by steve francia and is
made awesome today by bjorn eric
peterson it's similar to tools like
jekyll and eleventy but hugo is written
in go and achieve sub millisecond
rendering times it's fun to go fast but
more importantly it's an extremely
powerful content management system
authors create content by writing
markdown which gets rendered to html
based on the structure of the file
system developers use templates to
control how the content is presented
unlike regular html it uses go templates
to interpolate and transform dynamic
data from your content templates can
define variables perform loops fetch
remote data and all kinds of other stuff
thanks to tons of built-in hugo
functions these templates are organized
into a hierarchy of layouts to minimize
code duplication while maximizing
flexibility and it can even manage
relationships between content types
thanks to its taxonomy system making it
easy to implement menus tags and
categories all without the need for
third party plugins it's used on awesome
websites like the cloudflare
documentation smashing magazine and
fireship io to get started install it on
your machine then generate a new site
create a new web page by writing
markdown in the content directory or
better yet use the cli to generate it
which provides a default schema that can
be customized in the archetypes
directory now at this point you can
install a theme by adding a git sub
module to the themes directory or
structure the html from scratch using
layouts we might start with a default
base of template which will be rendered
on every page and has access to
variables about the site like page has
access to the front matter metadata and
the markdown and site has access to
global data that we might find in that
file now within the template blocks can
be defined that can be overridden by
other templates for example the main
content is entirely different on a
single post versus a list of posts the
single template can simply render the
html content from the markdown the list
template though will need to loop over a
range of pages in that directory then
render a truncated preview of the
content the website will also likely
need a sidebar menu which can be coded
as a partial template that can be reused
in other layouts hugo creates a tree of
sections based on your content structure
that can be used to build dynamic menus
in addition it has many other built-in
features like syntax highlighting image
processing multilingual support and
shortcodes but now run hugo server from
the terminal to view your site in the
browser and admire that blazingly fast
build time this has been hugo in 100
seconds hit the like button if you want
to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one